we do it all the time nice
[Music]
right hand
and that circle is going to slide that
home so it's going to extend and spiral
a little bit to hand yes
ticket Kimmy and I end up back up on the
set on one he hadn't sent in mine and
now I
wait is over the power man loses the
back
[Music]
that's the pattern but my front lower
leg is over my ankle I'm not pushing out
like this and my back foot is outer edge
down and there's a slight knee pin in my
back light so I'm not like this okay so
if he gets up and pushes me here get on
this then this is a bracelet what if I
change it all then this is a grounding
pack so I could do go ahead
I could do this and it's just going down
okay this is something different and
marshaling with weapons that's the over
extension we not gonna be able to back
out very quickly if you need to so same
movement Oh
okay
he's letting my sword push or my joke
push his weapon he's not anticipating
the energy I was giving him he utilizes
you don't Dookie - all right tell me
Johannes go over there the reason you'll
have to go over there is because we hit
your weapon
you didn't absorb it so if you go slow
I'm going to start to draw so I'm gonna
free the sword that's what you're doing
your hands get knocked over there you
didn't free the sword we're better said
I don't want the sword to ever be
captured so I'm moving and everyone is
different everyone's that torch is
different it's you kami
[Music]
then I don't look at his head I know
where his head is as I see his shoulders
and on most people it's higher than the
shoulders in the middle so I don't let
the target capture Oh mice myself I
don't look like that
and I shouldn't have to look to judge
range I should have practiced enough
that I know how long the sword is so if
I I stay in the fight boom okay let's go
so the other day we talked about or I
wrote about the stinky body so if I do a
kind of sticky hand see I'll let that
hand go by so my body stays relatively
still and I absorbed the energy this way
Aikido the only Aikido doesn't do that
hand Aikido does the body so my hand
generally stays in the same relationship
and I moved by one well I don't you see
here it mean you got close to me boom
and the other one it won't get close to
me
same concept here a lot of you are
absorbing this with your hands so he's
pushing down and you going around like
that so what I'm going to do is not move
this sword you can go a little slower
I'm not going to move the sword from top
to bottom from left to right you see
that I'm gonna move my body around the
swords you gotta go slow
so has this sort of moved from its
original place no I that's it then if I
want to go on distorting to go on this
side to him then I moved my body on that
side of it this hands have not moved
you've seen then I just rotate I'm
allowed rotation in Aikido but my hands
are still on my centerline BC and then
they come up
[Music]
this is very different see that
difference tell my hands stay still and
I moved my body home oh okay Chinese so
I feel Oh
I don't go oh he he said keep it so keep
it that you didn't move your Center you
yield to keep it
boom okay I'm gonna meet his his weapon
[Music]
make sure
reach out then absorb how to make
connection boom that's what I'm here I'm
not gonna sit here and let him hit my
I'm gonna make connection initially whoa
my body has to allow itself to go in
when there's in and to come back out
when there's dog to go lower right with
their job and to come up when their skin
do you understand
it's very different from this so there's
a kin right here then then y'all then
again
it is going to be different every time
aho basic to Aikido is you don't let
their force output manipulate your
Center your posture your mouth wherever
you're at whatever I penetrate with you
neutralized with your movement whatever
it's going to be whether it be off to
the side off to the back rotational
lower higher you move the degree of
penetration you are in communion with
their young energy so this is a very
simple drill you're just going to go
slow and all you have to do is not move
more not move less not move early not
move late do you understand that's all
you're trying to do so I'm helping him
there was a little little happiness
there that's where you end up swinging
your arms around on tailors no I'll give
you some energy
that's better reach out reach out yes
contact absorbs there you go reach out
yes so in the same way that you fell
into that empty space I should should
not have that and see if it wasn't empty
do you see that I should fall into that
interface there you go
see how a month
so how much feel he's weighed see and I
absorbed that so we're partners I'm
training ham
[Music]
so he is going to keep pushing slowly
just like I am pushing here pull a
little too much right old and keep
pushing and I move my body to absorb Hey
oh just food it's gonna cover yourself
this is pretty quick is to turn right
so are your hair cool you just put it up
don't do anything weird
cover yourself then free the pressure
with your body move